we're we're very confident and and where
we are uh as far as the
the 80-man roster so you know as far as
any prospect that's that's uh available
you know those those are more
conversations for
for jerry steven and and
will mcclay you know as far as looking
at
that situation so i i have nothing
really to report he is absolutely one of
my favorite all-time uh competitors i
love the guy but at this time uh that's
a position that uh we're not looking to
add to uh but yeah he is absolutely one
of my favorite all-time competitors so
love the guy but not a spot um that
we're looking to add to at this time no
it's been been a tough time for earl you
know that that's a hard hard situation
um
no i feel bad for him
you know could he could have
avoided that from happening whatever it
was i don't know what happens
particularly but um that's a bad state
to get in when they send you home
that last one from pete carroll reminded
me of jerry seinfeld periodically
uttering that's a shame
that's a shame yeah that's a shame that
happened to the guy who gave me the
middle finger's way off the field the
last time he ever played for me yeah
that's a that's a shame for a guy who
was probably a constant irritant for
pete carroll the past couple of years
that they were together in seattle so
look
uh
i i didn't expect a land rush no for
earl thomas because people around the
league understand the limitations of the
player and they need to understand the
realities of the locker room there's a
lot of homework to be done there's a lot
of due diligence to be accomplished what
happened in seattle yeah what happened
in baltimore people have been buzzing
about this incessantly for the last
three days and anyone who's even
remotely plugged into the broader nfl
grapevine has heard the horror stories
you're not going to run after earl
thomas simply because he happens to be a
be available this is something that's
going to take some time may require an
injury may need some time for him to
kind of cool off and understand he needs
to humble himself
changes in the way he approaches
teammates and the way he approaches the
game if he does that he could be
attractive and i still i
i i have been burned by this enough
times that i am not going to take my eye
off of bill belichick eventually at the
right time for the right price swooping
in and grabbing earl thomas as that same
style of middle finger that he gave to
pete carroll belichick will be given to
john harbaugh and the ravens when they
take their guy and they turn him into a
productive member of the defense after
he's been appropriately humbled by the
passage of time and the lack of interest
well i mean that certainly would be a
place that that could you know yeah turn
him around make him adapt to the culture
you know as we've talked about so many
times i will say this i wouldn't expect
it just because there is great depth at
that position there and i know they lost
patrick chung certainly but man
belichick collects
those safety hybrid type players because
they're so important to a secondary um
but but it is a new england type move so
i mean again you're right i don't want
to say it too like strongly either
because as soon as you say it strongly
two weeks later he'll be signed you know
the reality is hey we always heard
dallas fart with them you know
christopher shard's not there anymore
the prior relationship with you know
seattle and earl thomas he's not there
they're running a different scheme and
you know back to what we talked about
yesterday you know this is not a player
that is as you know the player he was
three or four years ago this is a very
very in the middle of the pack free
safety you know he's not better than the
two safeties with the atlanta falcons
you know he's not better than the two
safeties with the dallas cowboys and
certainly not in seattle with that right
there and the big thing is yes what you
said and what pete carroll said you know
it's it's not a good look when you get
you have to really really be disliked by
your team in an organization to get
kicked off a team the way earl thomas
did and that's going to make everybody
like like you said sit back let me call
some people
let me talk to this guy what the hell
really happened there and you know maybe
somebody will finally get an answer that
they feel comfortable with that they'll
start to dabble in the business of earl
thomas once again or you get injuries
like mike and i don't mean to jump the
shark here but like the cleveland browns
okay
yesterday they lose a safety i thought
of them right away okay just because
grant delphi he's a second round pick
out of lsu
and i i know you're probably supposed to
break this news but i just jumped into
my mind to go because that's cleveland
and they run the seattle scheme joe
woods just came from san francisco he's
the d coordinator there so right away i
went ooh that's the type of scenario
where an earl thomas could get on a team
and be in a system that fits him that
way and i think it's going to take
something like that at this point i do
it's not quite a simsism
but that's not what jump the shark means
you understand that i don't even know
what it means
you jumped ahead yes on the outline
which is fine it's already out there
that grant delpin has a torn achilles
tendon he's lost for the uh torn
achilles tendon loss for the season
second round draft pick and and now they
have a need and you know other needs may
arise jump the shark for those of you
who have heard the phrase but aren't
quite sure what it means like chris that
is a reference to the episode of happy
days when they put fonzie in his leather
jacket t-shirt and shorts and he did a
water skiing jump
over a shark pen
and and that was the moment where the
series went off the rails when it was no
longer what it originally was so you
jump the shark when you that wasn't all
i was just a point okay
when you reach a point where it's like
it's done this is over they're desperate
now it's not what it used to be so
before we jump the shark let's uh get
back to what we were talking about
i i think that that his best play is
going to be to sit and wait for an
injury and sit and wait to the phone
phone to ring whether it is the browns
calling up now now that grant delpid is
out for the year now look they've got
they've got two safeties who are injured
including delp but they've got four
corners who are currently out good luck
getting through practice with with six
of your defensive backs gone currently
um so you know maybe the browns give
them a call maybe somebody else gives
them a call we know injury is going to
happen especially once we get into the
season yeah you know there haven't been
many season-ending injuries so far in
camp
i think because they've been going easy
on the guys once it gets to the games
you know again i don't this is more of a
general jinx and it's an inevitable jinx
we know it's going to happen maybe earl
thomas just just waits for that takes
solace in the possibility of winning his
grievance and my guess is his agents are
telling him we got a good case even if
they don't and uh yeah so he's hey i'm
getting 10 million either way i'm just
going to wait for the right opportunity
to come around yeah yeah i mean i think
you know ultimately that's what it's
going to take too i don't think
anybody's going to just feel comfortable
enough right now at this moment to go oh
we need him because he's that good or we
need to pay him that kind of money
because he's that good or you know we
you know we need him who cares what he
did on his last team i don't care no you
know the player is just not good enough
to warrant that type of signing anymore
like you talked about with antonio brown
before
yeah teams might have known he was a
pain in the butt they didn't care
because when they turn on the film they
went oh my gosh i think this is the best
receiver in football i can deal with the
issues we'll all fix the issues you know
but when you're not that like player on
the film anymore you know the guys don't
want to deal with you and your issues
coaches don't want to deal with that
there are some teams out there that are
thin at the safety position to play that
seattle scheme we mentioned the browns
the colts are a team that you know
safety play has not been great for them
they run that seattle scheme the
jacksonville jaguars is another team
mike that jumps out to me there and
along with your bill bella check thought
too i'll throw another one out the
detroit lions you know they're another
team matt patricia his offensive
coordinators daryl bevel who's been in
seattle around earl thomas they don't
have great depth or talent at that
position you know i'm just throwing out
a few teams that i think could maybe
have him on their radar for the in case
one more guy gets hurt we might have to
call earl thomas and his representation
yeah and see this is how it works at
every organization especially this time
of year they will have a room somewhere
in the facility and on one side of the
room they will have their roster broken
down by position with a
loose depth chart of where everyone sits
on it 90 or no 80 names this year 90 in
a normal year and then on the other side
of the room they'll have categories
receiver tackle guard center right
quarterback running back safety
all the way across with their preferred
list of the guys that they would call
if an injury happens to one of the guys
on the other wall
and and the question for these teams
chris is where does earl thomas fit
on that list of 10 names under free
safety right do you put him at the top
is he the first guy you call do you put
him farther down i mean as as all free
safeties that are currently out there
he'd have to be the top guy
the question is how much are you going
to pay him how much are you going to
want how much is in the tank and what
kind of a problem is he potentially
going to be in your locker room given
the problem he was in baltimore's locker
yeah you know and that's a good question
and you're right i mean i would think
he's towards the top of the list the
name that does jump to my mind right
away a little bit is rashad jones right
my ex miami dolphins player i do believe
he's still out there right now i could
be wrong but i'm pretty sure he was
still a free agent but yeah i would
think that with the available guys on
the street those would be the two guys
that teams are gonna look at you know
experienced not going to be overwhelmed
by anything mentally know how to play
the game professionals that way
yes i would think that is the case with
earl thomas as long as he you know yeah
shows a little bit of a humbleness or a
changing of his ways and yeah not that
he's gonna you know that he won't ask
for for big time money or anything like
that which i don't think he'll be able
to at this point
i think back to the cam newton situation
even though the circumstances were
dramatically different it was his injury
the inability to check him out because
of the pandemic the panthers squatting
on him longer than they should have all
those things came together to put him on
the shelf for as long as he was but that
process of being on the shelf for that
long of being available of having those
doubts the uncertainty as every day goes
by and the phone does not ring that's
what softened him up for the move the
patriots eventually made and that's why
i refuse
to remove
that blip from my radar screen chris yep
that there's the possibility that bill
belichick is just waiting and keeping
his mouth shut
and at the right moment he's going to
get the right guy with the right mindset
at the right price with the right
attitude to come in and not be a problem
submit to the patriot way
and become
yet another key player on a team that is
retooling on the fly with patrick chung
opting out even though patrick chung's a
strong safety and earl thomas is a free
safety bill belichick would find a way
to use him i i just i will not take that
possibility off the list i i hear you i
i mean you know we've seen them do this
before and this is earl thomas who
you know bill belichick has had a
first-hand experience to know how good
that guy is in a super bowl you know in
a sunday night football game up in new
england when i was working there we new
england went out to seattle and that was
you know you mad at me bro game when
richard sherman was yelling that to you
know tom brady and all that but here
just the free agents that are out there
old thomas rashad jones we talked about
tony jefferson right the baltimore
safety who got hurt last year he didn't
get to play he's out there eric reed's
out there he's still the starting
caliber safety morgan burnett you know
antoine bethea getting a little long in
the tooth but still was solid last year
for the new york jets so there is a
little more competition out there in you
know free safety and safety out there in
free agency land than than i expected
they don't have you know the stars you
know what do i want to say the
they don't have the the career earl
thomas has but but either way there's
some guys out there
oh and by the way if earl thomas would
land with the new england patriots we
would see him twice this year on nbc
week two against seattle week 10
against baltimore whoa that would be
amazing i'm now officially rooting now
and the patriots to sign earl tom
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports